so in the movie of course we know that
our third Aquaman gets his badass moves
from his mama
so what's one badass move you got from
your mom oh it's at souther and it's at
southern in Seoul
thank you mom I told him my mother calls
it as a smile oh yeah my mom says kill
him with kindness
I was always confused by that but now
hey so you know the chase scene in this
movie kind of reminded all of us of
Quantum of Solace from the Bond movie
Daniel Craig says after this year he's
gonna be done we're still advocating for
a woman to meet bond what do you think
baby would you real what you doing a
great bond listen now you've got in the
superhero realm you know how to slide
you kicking somebody's behind yeah yeah
I think I could it's about time do you
have any big holiday plans I just be
with my family my little sister is
having a baby
any minute now I mean she's she's
somewhere around here bumping into
people yeah she's about to give birth I
mean we keep saying it would be amazing
it for water broke at Aquaman premiere
be very very amazing we're waiting for
it any day we're asking celebrities to
describe 2018 with a sound not a word
but a sound
what would you say 2018
you
[Music]